it's springtime time to get motivated to
clean out and get organized here again
as professional home organizer JC patino
thanks for being with us last half hour
now you showed us how to organize our
kitchen to declutter you gotta edit now
let's tackle some drawers in our closets
and in our our bedrooms one of the worst
things for me is knowing how to fold
things and then I just throw it all in
there on top of everything each other
and I can't find what I'm looking for
but you've got some ways to beat that
yes and so and thanks for having me
again of course so usually like athletic
talks women so we want to file fold
those are the most challenging yes and
file folding is where it is all lined up
so you can see everything you have okay
and so with athletic tops you can see
the strappies yeah the Razorbacks and
the spaghetti straps those are the
hardest and so immediately you want to
fold those down get those out of your
way okay and then we are going to fold
into thirds so you get rid of the uneven
Corners is that it so you don't have to
think about those okay these all right
make it Square make it all even and we
are just going to fold all right and now
we have this we can stack up like that
so baskets are handy in closets and
drawers right containing and labeling
containing and labeling that's good so
then everyone knows what is what and
where it's going okay so if there's if
the if your kid's looking for something
if your husband's looking for something
there's no questions of where is where
it is it is clearly labeled okay so that
says athletic wear on it okay so then
you got these strappy sports bras same
thing same thing and so that's where
sometimes people are just like I'm just
gonna throw it yeah throw it in the bin
but if you fold it down you can easily
then fold it into the thirds get rid of
the straps and then we can
and then show everybody what that looks
like tilt that up okay so you're saying
stack it vertically not horizontally so
instead of stacking it on top of each
other you're saying stack it one in
front of the other like this yeah so
then you can see what everything is does
that work for jeans too yep jeans and uh
also all kids clothes our own clothes
that works yep all righty and then
anything that's huh for hanging oh right
let's tackle the hanging stuff um
hanging is something that it is
you might have a ton of different
hangers in your closet right right over
the years you've switched the plastic
ones the wire ones all that and so an
easy fix is to switch out all the
hangers to a thin hanger that all is
universal it's going to save space and
also as you're switching out each
individual item to another hanger you're
going to have be forced to look at that
clothing item and see yeah maybe I
haven't worn this in a couple of years
or more so then you can then go ahead
and donate that item okay all right and
then and then they all hang in the
closet together and it just makes it a
little more compressed gives you more
room yes so you don't have all those
uneven hangers yeah utilizes the best
amount of the most space you can okay
all right those are all great ideas I
know you've got so many more you've got
baskets good ways and you say you don't
need it if you if you haven't looked for
it in three months get rid of it
and donate it or just trash it such
great ideas thank you JC it was really
nice to meet you and if you want to get
a hold of JC we'll have her room Nation
your method is called the neat method
yes professional organizing but lots of
inexpensive ways to to stay organized
and decluttered all right Nate how many
of these methods do you use in your own
house well I I was thinking about that
but I just decided to hang it up hang it
up